[Music]
we're partnering with digital media
company refinery29 this morning for a
new series about millennials called my
generation they're people who were born
between the early 80s and mid 90s they
make up the largest living generation
bigger than baby boomers and Generation
X their money their attention and their
votes are all in big demand identifying
Millennials is complicated by a divide
within the generation their formative
years were split by the financial crisis
smartphones and social media bianna
golodryga met some Millennials to get
their reactions to stereotypes about
them beyond a good morning Oh Nora I
felt so old talking to this group of
kids we brought together a group they're
not kids actually they're adults and
they were group from across the country
featuring three Millennials age 30 to 34
and three younger Millennials ages 23 to
27 we met them at the New York City Bar
Porchlight to learn what unites and what
divides them there are a lot of
stereotypes some are true maybe some not
so true about what people say about
Millennials I'm gonna ask you if you
agree or disagree
Millennials are entitled I agree with ya
definitely agree
why do you agree I think we've been
conditioned to get used to being
comfortable with things coming to us
quickly things being more convenient for
us getting things quicker
well you led me into my next question
Millennials are lazy no I don't disagree
I disagree with that I work a full-time
job and then I come home and then run a
business that's why I think they were
not entitled is because of that
entrepreneurial spirit that many of us
have I think we're one of the hardest
working generations because of the
country that was left to us we have to
be because our generation and maybe this
is also part of the millennial divide
the younger Millennials came into the
workforce with more knowledge and
expertise in technology and social media
and so they're coming in and thinking
like I deserve more I deserve more
faster did you enter the job market
before or after the financial crisis
after work before after after okay
and and how would you say it has
impacted your view on your financial
situation and your career it has made me
extremely driven because when I first
entered the workforce there were very
limited jobs and so I was competing for
jobs with older men like 45 years old I
was in interviews with them I also think
that that is the difference between that
maybe entitlement piece that we're
talking about because and I don't fault
the younger Millennials for that they're
seeing you know 30 year old men being
CEOs and super successful and getting
billions of dollars and so I think
that's what they expect how many of you
still live with your parents or depend
on your parents for financial how do I
live with my parents but I don't depend
on them
yeah same you don't depend on your
parents but you live at their house how
does that work so I pay all my own yeah
yes let's move on
Millennials are overly sensitive and
need praise that's really hurtful for
you to say take a moment very aggressive
feel like they need a trophy things more
reversing that thing I mean I think that
a lot of what we do isn't taken in isn't
respected you know I think that there's
a disconnect with previous generations
than us that there's not a respect for
the skills that we do on a regular basis
that they can't doing a job doesn't
necessarily deserve a pat on the back I
mean you have a job to do and you did it
it's not like it congratulations you did
it you just did it
are you more likely to text or email
with somebody or actually talk to them
on the phone probably text I talk it's
rude and intrusive to call someone to
call somebody I think that it can be
like depending on what you're going for
for example like I work in his sales job
if I call someone I feel like they are
more annoyed with me then if they can
just respond to a text on their own time
what is your overall perception on
younger Millennials I think overall
younger Millennials are very intelligent
I think they are very entrepreneurial I
think that they are entitled but I don't
necessarily believe that that is a bad
thing in all cases I think younger
Millennials had it a little harder than
us in terms of the constant pressure and
comparison from having social media all
the time
but I think the challenge is going to be
to kind of get better at listening in
addition to sort of projecting and
personally branding okay and let me ask
the younger Millennials what your
overall perception of your older peers
are they have a lot of the qualities
that we have and they have a lot of the
qualities that the older generation has
so we can glean a lot from them because
of that I mean I agree completely you
guys are like the transitional right you
know generation or phase and you guys
are kind of spearheading spiriting our
older generation as a whole so we're
just falling bread crumbs so lay the
bricks Luke was like our sleeper old
soul among the group well Millennials
are arguably more ambitious educated and
informed than generations before them
there is a perception that they are not
in a rush to settle professionally that
of course can lead to the misperception
of being lazy and entitled one of the
questions I obviously asked yeah Jana
thank you Aimee Emmerich is chief
content officer at refinery29 and is
also with us now
Aimee good morning you guys do a great
job of so many Millennials love your
site and you really sort of capture the
zeitgeist all cultural political issues
what do you think some of these
misperceptions come about Millennials I
mean I think the Millennial became a bad
word for a hot second because people
believe that they were lazy and entitled
but the laziness is really more about
self-care they may not be in an office
from 8 to 8 but they are much more about
involvement right how can they be better
with a work/life balance and I think the
entitlement comes with maybe a little
but it's about entitled to be seen and
heard and I think that's where they're
really kind of pushing the idea of
representation across media and other
otherwise driven by larger concerns than
personal concerns yes absolutely but you
know this generation is the one of the
most financially literate of many many
generations but the older set of
Millennials are much more focused on
that long-term planning homeownership
career well the younger set is much more
about experiences living in the now how
do I bottle up the now and really drive
with my passions
I agree with Norah about what refinery29
does it's not just from Linnaeus I think
if you want to know what's going on with
the younger generation read your website
yeah what do you think that they're
concerned about that other generations
are not that
stands out for you I think the societal
norms and breaking those down they grew
up with social media they are allowed to
say that what is motherhood career
relationships is not the way that the
generations before wrote those rules so
they're rewriting them across the board
and I think that until that they feel it
fits more of who they are they expect us
to all operate with more of a moral
value and compass than businesses before
and until they succeed in that they
won't stop pushing things alrighty yeah
oh absolutely also they create culture I
mean everyday through social media
they're doing it faster they consume it
faster and create more than any
generation and their own personal brands
I found are very important to them and I
talked about this is a difference in
previous generation yeah personal brand
thing is always baffling to me because I
just think you work and do a good job
and I hear so many in the window saying
I'm working on my brand so much